("Hit Me Up / 3 A.M." by Jaylien)
- [Jordan] How you feeling?
- [Gary] The sake, man.
(laughter)
- He's gonna go throw up.
Don't put that in. (laughs)
(text blips)
- So, uh...
Time stamp this DRock.
A little bit more in-between
time than normal because
at the end of the workout,
I don't know if you caught that,
but something hit me.
I clearly ate
something last night,
so I've been
throwing up all morning,
and now back to work.
("Summers Over" by Jaylien)
I threw up all over myself.
I mean, I didn't.
I just threw up in
the toilet, but ugh.
Clearly ate
something last night so,
it's gonna be a long day
on that kind of energy.
- [Paul] Can I say hi to
you for a quick second?
- [Gary] Sure.
- I actually met you at Soho
store, where you did the...
- Yes, book signing.
- After Crush It!, the next one,
and I do watch you on YouTube,
and I saw you on the Larry
King Show, blah, blah, blah.
You're amazing, getting chills
but thank you for everything.
- Thank you, thank you.
What's your name?
- Paul.
- Paul, real pleasure,
thanks for saying hello.
- Nice to see you.
- Yeah, man, I wish you well.
- How are you?
Good to see you.
- Hey guys, how are you?
- Hey.
- Hi, how are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you,
good to see you.
- Good.
- [Gary] All well?
Boy, I feel weird.
- 'Sup, gang?
Good to see you, yeah.
What's up?
- [Man] You're back.
- We're back.
- Oh, I missed you.
- Missed you too, hey James.
- [Claude] Are we on?
- Yeah, we're on.
How's it going?
- [Claude] It's going.
We missed you.
- It's good to be back.
- Yeah, I'm sorry you feel bad.
Two months ago, that's the
only other time I remember you,
like stomach stuff.
- Yeah, it feels so weird.
- [Claude] I'm so sorry.
- That's our real thing.
- [Claude] That's our real thing.
- We're a little early, like
in our combination of it.
I think it's the biggest
pillar we play on.
thing we're doing.
- [Claude] Anything I can
do to scale you.
- You're doing a great
job. I'm super pumped.
Honestly, what I'm more
worried about actually,
it's why I pinged you on the,
"Let's look at positivity."
I'm just scared that that's
not even a good deal for me,
got it?
That's what's not
allowing me to do this.
I'm being dead serious with you.
I'm gonna sell
400,000 copies
in the first week
of my next book,
and things have to have
real meat on the bones.
I think for sure.
Here's a big thing.
I think this thing
breaks if it's on me
to tell you what to do.
- Andy! Yeah, okay.
Did you have lunch with Argen?
Hey Facebook, it's me,
Gary Vaynerchuk,
former host of
Wine Library TV.
If you're seeing this video,
I'm running Facebook ads against
fans of me and Wine Library
and other wine interests.
- [Man 2] I saw that
on the #AskGaryVee.
- Can I ask you
a weird question
that actually just
spurred to my mind?
- [Man 2] Nuh-uh.
- It's a good question.
It's a good question.
Do you think I'm a better
guy now by being here?
- [Man 2] No.
- No? Have you been proud of--
The way you said it
was such a warm thing.
- [Man 2] What's that?
- Just like,
we haven't been close in a
business setting in a long time.
- [Man 2] I know!
- I know even,
for example, my mother,
who do I love more
than my mom?
My wife!
By the way, there's a lot
of people that don't know
how great of a guy I really am
because they
don't have the data,
and I don't talk about it.
- [Man 2] I drank the
Kool-aid long ago.
- [Gary] Of course,
you know who I am but--
- [Man] Like when
I'm on the phone
with these people recruiting
I say, "I've been working
for the CEO for 15 years
for a reason.
- [Gary] Yup.
- [Man 2] It's easy.
It's easy.
- [Gary] It's really great
when there's black and
white examples though.
- [Man 2] No matter what
industry you're freaking in
I don't care.
- 100%
- [Man 2] They would
make the other decision.
- [Gary] 100%
- [Man 2] And that ripples
through these people.
- No question.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 224
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
All right.
- [Dunk] Cool.
- [Gary] What's up?
(mumbling)
It's gonna be
what it's gonna be.
- It is what it is, yeah.
- Yeah.
I don't know if
you guys recalled,
but I had a massive
request to have--
- [Woman] Oh yes,
your face on the wall.
- Yes.
- [Woman] Who's on it?
- [Man 3] We're gonna just
do one giant Gary face.
- [Woman] Can we put
you up there?
- [Gary] You guys can
do anything you want.
What you can't do
is not do something.
- [Woman] We're on it!
- Hey, how are you?
- [Woman 2] Good, how are you?
- Good, I loved all your
Instagram photos.
She's rockin' it!
Yes, this is fucking awesome!
- Hello. The slide,
or the artwork?
- All right, who knows who that is?
- [Woman 3] Oh, I don't know.
- [Gary] Not one of you
know who that is?
(people chatter over each other)
- [Gary] Po?
- I couldn't tell you the name.
- [Gary] Guys,
it's Mr. Sandman.
He's the hardest
boxer in this game.
He's tougher than Tyson.
Tyson has a pattern.
Sandman's got one
tweak to a pattern.
It's the only weird alternative,
and he's the only guy
that gave me trouble.
This is not in the right order,
because Super Macho
Man was before Sandman.
(faint chuckling)
Who put this thing together?
(laughing)
All right, that's something that,
a human that
gets this forwarded to
that doesn't give
a fuck about us
and is best friends with
the creative director from
(silent censoring)
if they're gonna just be careful
that a senior person
gave them a deck
and they just at least
want to know it's on there
because they have no fucking
interest in working with us,
that's the kind of thing that
may get them to say, "Huh."
I just want to put actually
Vayner work January 1st through,
do you see what I mean?
The reason I'm good at
selling is it's seconds.
The reason why
everyone thinks I'm a jerk
'cause I talk over everybody
is 'cause you're
losing in the room.
It's already over.
Unfortunately it's so sad,
that's why politicians
do what they do.
This stuff always
plays the best.
It's really so sad that we
live in a society where like,
"Hey you suck shit,"
is usually the best way to
get somebody to do something.
It sucks but--
(laughing)
- Yeah yeah,
I'll get back with you.
- Yeah, but we don't want to be.
I desperately don't want to be.
Alright, hurry.
Come on in, you want a co--
You're good?
Come on in, come on.
I don't wanna lose any time.
Just need to see
one thing from him.
("We FCUK" by Jaylien)
- Love ya, pal.
- [Gary] I saw a headline,
it went well?
- [Woman 3] It went
really well today, yeah.
He's gonna meet with--
- Great, what's up gang?
- How are you?
- How you doin'?
- Good.
- Hello.
- Hey.
(laughing)
- Good day.
- Yeah, it's funny,
getting your
feedback on this stuff
just made me realize,
we're never gonna win
playing the other game.
Every time you
talk a different change.
- Every time.
- That just needs
to be the feedback.
- What do you think
this has been all about?
- Yeah, but even I forget.
If I forget it it's easier for--
- [Gary] But it's really
just one replication
of who I am as a human.
I lost in school.
- [Jon] It's the only reason
you got this whole staff.
- [Gary] People don't get it.
I've been trying
to tell everybody.
I'm bad at normal.
I don't know how
to win that game.
- [Jon] Right.
- Genuinely, I can't
win in normal stuff.
- [Jon] Right.
- [Gary] Maybe I'll
do a little talk in here.
- [DRock] Okay.
- Jumping into three
drinks here at Lure,
a great little restaurant
in New York City, in Soho.
I don't think DRock's gonna
go in and jam with me
so we'll catch up with
you in a little bit.
Good day though.
It's unbelievable
how intoxicating
getting back on
the action is for me,
and I missed you, DRock.
- DRock, this is for you,
show 'em I'm still hustling
on Twitter and Snapchat.
Right now, 12:30, and
I gotta get up in five minutes.
(light music)